[Music]
we say some people have an eye for
design but ron norsworthy is notable for
all the places he casts his talented
gaze including that music video by missy
elliott he's designed buildings and been
an art director and production designer
for influential music videos even movies
and he created stylish products for the
home i met up with him and learned how
his biggest creative project might be
his own ever-changing career
wow you took over the entire space yeah
it's a site-specific work ron norsworthy
has a track record of making art that
pops from the canvas to the flat screen
a mastermind is both director and set
designer of some of pop culture's most
influential moments as i look back on my
contribution to these sort of iconic
videos part of the reason that they
worked was my point of view was very
different i didn't come from the hip-hop
community
i was a fan but
i wasn't an insider rather he learned to
wear the role of outsider growing up in
the midwest he attended eight schools by
the age of 18. often the only person of
color struggling to make connections and
be seen i knew i wasn't like everybody
else i knew i needed to start imagining
worlds that i fit in
princeton wasn't easy either after
graduation he found his footing working
as the youngest architect at a prominent
firm
months later he was laid off could you
have just gotten another job at another
firm
yeah so but what happened
architecture was starting to
feel like it had limitations okay for me
i went to visit lots of sets while i was
still working for michael graves
architect
and i saw myself there
something just clicked i remember
writing in my journal if i work in music
videos i can make a hundred and
twenty-five dollars a day as a pa if i
work this many days i can pay my rent
and of course i had a friend but i had
to ask her that was one of those times
where i was like i know i can do it just
give me a chance and she believed it and
she said yes and we also co-wrote the
concept for let's talk about sex too
he had arrived even featuring himself in
the video the salt and peppa hit was the
first of many for norrisworthy he would
go on to work as assistant art director
on spike lee's crookland
and associate art director for the
hughes brothers dead presidents his
vision was essential in hip-hop
sensation missy elliot's first ever
music video the rain i brought more of a
pop sensibility i brought more of a
queer sensibility there's an absurdity
to the sets that i made they were very
powerful norsworthy began to specialize
in building sets for performers like
destiny's child on mtv's trl or this
unforgettable cake for madonna at the
vmas he was intentional about allying
with other voices working with mostly
women and behind the scenes ensuring
that his staff received equal pay
but he needed to do more there was less
and less time to be the artist that i
imagined that i wanted to be so you were
really struggling to hold on to your
real identity as a queer black man again
i'm still in spaces that i'm the only
one even on hip-hop music videos that
wasn't necessarily the safest space for
me either he found solace in making the
groundbreaking artwork reparation tower
an interactive rendering of condos in
harlem new york the work brought into
question topics of equality and
gentrification if you chose the colored
entrance
you got a plexiglass enclosure like you
find at liquor stores in harlem
you can see it
but you can't have access
a lot of people haven't experienced the
success with
music videos and set design would be
very very happy to stay in that space
yes michelle but i think that i just
know myself i know who i am and i know
what i can do and you would move beyond
that and i had moved beyond all of it
and so he did building a
multi-disciplinary design firm the
norrisworthy fund was about a fund of
ideas i was going to fund your project
with my creativity trying to get
back to
being the master of my destiny
art had to be the center
it had to be the center designing rooms
for celebrities like tyra banks and
runways for fashion week leading him to
become the first african-american man to
sell his own designs on qbc uk the new
posh turns dressing your bed into an art
form
oh so you what a silk screen it's silk
it's screened yeah and so my process is
about mixing i can take things that are
from one context uncouple them and give
them new meaning they're hypervisible
today he's more of a conventional artist
with a twist from candles and wallpaper
to collages like the photo of wheezy and
george jefferson in the bedroom of
thomas jefferson what is it with the
blurred faces so that is a way of kind
of being influenced by that oral
tradition of telling a story over and
over again if you notice the
architecture is a little bit
disorienting in each of these works and
i wanted to somehow convey
our
culture's disorientation with the
telling of american history
i don't know why he's so much faster
than me he continues this work at darn
studios his practice with his husband
david and with the orange i think it
looks great
quilting matchbooks made with the
numeric code for the names and dates of
police brutality victims
simultaneously we're talking about
how the killing of brown and black
people was happening at such a rate we
weren't remembering everybody
a creative who's been in a lot of spaces
he's certainly found his place
in every one of them i realized i was
never going to belong anywhere until i
belonged
in comfortable in my own skin first what
would the world be like if people felt
comfortable in their in their own skin
i mean
we wouldn't have
a lot of the issues that were dealing
with that message of feeling comfortable
in your own skin
belonging to yourself first
is a very kind of instructive message
for
how we could live our lives better
he kind of blew me away i mean there
isn't any aspect of the artistic
creative that isn't in him he's got a
mural that will be in the new newark uh
international airport at the united
terminal he's got a board game coming
out
that was funded by the andy warhol
foundation and oh by the way that is all
visual right he he even has like our
sense of smell that he's about to engage
with some new some new sets of candles
that he hopes to to uh put on on the
market i love that he wants to explore
all those areas because his creativity
in each space is different and brings
something different which welcomes
everybody else in it's really can add
something in all those yeah